president Trump is fueling new
controversy over one of the most solemn
duties of any president speaking to
families of troops killed in action the
White House says a president's chief of
staff John Kelly did not get a call from
then President Obama when Kelly's son a
Marine lieutenant was killed in
Afghanistan mr. Trump brought up the
issue in a radio interview the president
is also accused of being insensitive in
a phone call to a widow of a green beret
killed in West Africa earlier this month
she received the call while on the way
to greet her husband's casket at the
airport details of the conversation come
from a Democratic congresswoman who
overheard the call Margaret Brennan is
at the White House with more on all of
this Margaret good morning good morning
the president spoke last night with the
families of all four of those Green
Berets killed in Nazaire and thanked
them for their service
but in defending his own response to the
attack the president ignited another
controversy
president Trump frequently speaks of his
respect for US military leaders like his
chief of staff John Kelly a retired
Marine general on Tuesday he thrust
Kelly into the spotlight to make a
political point I mean you could ask
General Kelly did he get a call from
Obama
you could ask other people I don't know
what Obama's policy was Kelly who
declined to comment has made clear in
the past he does not want his son
Robert's death exploited and rarely
speaks publicly about it there are no
words that can make it better I know
that a Memorial Day this year President
Trump visited Robert's grave and called
attention to his loss Robert died
fighting the enemies of all
civilizations in Afghanistan earlier
this week mr. Trump claimed that past
commanders in chief did not always call
gold star families President Obama and
other presidents most of them didn't
make also a lot of them didn't make
calls acclaimed swiftly refuted by
presidents Clinton Bush and Obama mr.
Trump made it while defending why it
took 12 days to publicly acknowledge the
deaths of the four Green Berets
including sergeant Lee David Johnson on
Tuesday sergeant Johnson's remains were
transferred back to his widow in Miami
who also took a condolence call from
the president Florida Democrat and
congresswoman Federico Wilson was with
Johnson when mr. Trump called
he never said the word hero he said to
the wife well I guess you know what he
was getting into the president tweeted
this morning that Wilson fabricated her
account but the congresswoman is
standing by her version of events
Myesha Johnson has not responded to
requests for comment by CBS News now the
White House still hasn't explained why
it took the president 12 days to
publicly acknowledge the deaths but did
explain that it took until this Monday
for them to vet the information provided
by the Pentagon and confirm that the
next-of-kin had been notified of the
deaths all right Margaret Brennan there
at the White House thank you so much